vous avez vu aujourd'hui qu'agathe un
gâteau proulx voilà qu'on aime
énormément ce avait décidé de quitter
l'aventuré pmp et btp
voilà c'est vrai qu'elle a eu énormément
de soucis de santé c'est ce qu'elle
explique voilà ce qu'elle vous explique
c'est vrai que voilà elle a envie pour
l'instant de passe à autre chose de
faire autre chose voilà
et on la comprend tout à fait et je
voulais juste dire agathe voilà qu'on
l'aimé énormément qu'elle revient quand
elle veut la porte est toujours ouverte
pour elle et ça a été un grand talent
qui était avec nous dans tpm paix ont la
soutiendra bien sûr dans ses nouveaux
projets et on espère voilà que si elle
veut faire de la télé bon voilà on la
soutiendra et j'espère qu'elle sera un
jour en invités ou bien voilà je crois
qu'elle veut faire d'autres choses qu'à
c'est vrai qu'elle a écrit son livre qui
marche très bien
voilà en tout cas on embrasse très fort
car elle sera toujours la bienvenue dans
tempo et on comprend son choix est
vraiment voilà c'était et c'est toujours
un très gros talent voilà je le dis et
je pense qu'elle va très vite
voilà faire aussi en tout cas faire ce
qui lui plaît en tout cas voilà ici ça
lui plaisait la dic avait passé deux
années et demie magnifique mais c'est
vrai qu'elle a envie de faire autre
chose voilà j'espère que vous voilà vous
avez envie de rester en tout cas pour
ceux qui sont payés qu'ils aiment aller
les chéris